of activists in the u.s are entering the
third week of hunger strike
over the saudi blockade of yemen the
american-based
yemeni liberation movement is urging the
biden administration to make good on its
promise to end support to the saudi
campaign
well yemen is now in the grip of a
full-blown famine after a six-year
military onslaught by saudi arabia
those operations are aimed at propping
up yemen's pro-saudi government against
shia houthi fighters which riad claims
to be terrorists
the wars directly or indirectly claimed
almost a quarter of a million lives
according to the un
and the crisis appears to be getting
even worse with the saudi blockade
preventing vital supplies from entering
yemeni ports
top
[Music]
two
according to the un two million children
under the age of five will suffer acute
malnutrition in yemen this year
if the blockade continues it could
result in four hundred thousand deaths
we heard from one of the leading
activists involved in the hunger strike
she thinks a global response is needed
to end the war
we're not talking about just the united
states who's involved although they are
a vital supporter and a key supporter in
this in this role
i mean uh you know you have to involve
the united nations
uh france um spain and so many other
countries who are also
involved in in supplying arms to the
saudi coalition
but absolutely you know there should be
a a huge uproar i mean
we are literally day by day watching the
worst
humanitarian crisis in the world um you
know these are people that struggle to
find
water um and uh and uh struggle to
be able to afford food and just imagine
that this is
a constant daily life and why are we not
hearing from these world leaders why are
we not
hearing from from the from other nations
who should be extremely
outraged that this could be this could
happen to any other country and we
should
all equally be as enraged and absolutely
the world needs to talk more about
what's going on
you